l'algérie dans l'attenté de la
proclamation des résultats des
législatives anticipées de samedi l'un
des principaux partis de mouvance
islamiste a revendiqué la victoire
un scrutin largement boudé par les
électeurs avec un taux de participation
autour de 30 % seulement ont fait le
point avec ben hassen chébili sur place
les premiers résultats des élections
législatives anticipées algérienne
marqué par un fort taux d'abstention
toujours pas connue ce scrutin le
premier depuis le soulèvement populaire
contre un cinquième mandat de l'ex
président abdelaziz bouteflika a été
boycotté par le mouvement contestataire
du miracle et par une partie de
l'opposition qui y voit une mascarade
électorale tandis que les pro
gouvernement ont appelé à voter
massivement mais de son côté de
présidente et bull a déclaré que le taux
de participation n'avait pas
d'importance ce qui importe c'est que
les députés élus par le peuple est une
légitimité suffisante c'est en kabylie
au nord du pays que le taux de
participation a été quasi nulle
accompagné de tension et de saccage dur
hier soir le principal parti islamique
en liste le mouvement de la société pour
la paix a revendiqué la victoire selon
un communiqué de ce parti conservateur
considéré comme modéré mais aucun
résultat pour le moment même provisoire
n'a encore été annoncée en raison du
dépouillement compliqué le chef de
l'autorité nationale indépendante des
élections avait fait savoir samedi que
les résultats officiels pourraient ne
pas être annoncés avant plusieurs jours